this is a Scott an Arabian thoroughbred
he belongs to Saudi Arabia's royal
family but he lives here in Poland at
univ podlaski a renowned stud farm that
specializes in this expensive breed for
nearly 200 years Jana podlaski has been
known all over the world for its Arabian
horses but this year things have
suddenly been turned on their head marek
traelo the director of this illustrious
institution was fired from his job and
replaced by a government appointed
manager is that our vineyard with
Felicia next year the farm will be 200
years old it's a very special place not
just for me but for many people the
Atheist having to leave is very painful
for me put on these three anybody did
Yaniv has always been a state-run
institution I've always stayed out of
politics and so has the farms but
unfortunately the government is now
stepping into them to putting together
my foot
he's been replaced by an economist who
has no apparent knowledge of horses a
second stud farm has met the same fate
triggering public protests demonstrators
say Colin's new right-wing government is
riding roughshod over democratic norms
exerting its influence on the
Constitutional Court the media and now
the country stud farms hands off our
horses they say that vehicle was the
government doesn't satisfy but just
ruling other people now they want
animals as well it's a scandal is it wat
SIA many believe Poland's Law and
Justice Party wants to make money with
the stud farms to finance their campaign
promises the Minister of Agriculture
called a press conference to try to
explain the dismissals there were a
number of accusations of economic
mismanagement for veterinary care lack
of supervision we've sent the matter to
the public prosecutor's office and there
may be criminal offences involved the
government cited the unexplained death
of an arabian mayor last year as an
example of the directors in competence
equestrian journalist mark cheb chick
says the government's behavior is
totally unreasonable obvious today that
possessive and the stud farms always
made a profit under the old management
the government ought to be giving them
medals and holding them up as examples
in this difficult industry not firing
them the reasons they give are absurd
don't yet boy Anthony appointed took
down a suit once a year selected horses
are groomed with particular care ready
for auction the annual sale of Arabian
horses called the pride of Poland is a
highlight of the international
equestrian calendar ten-year-old pepita
sold for 1.4 million euros last year to
an anonymous buyer from Switzerland if
the director is so incompetent could his
horse really command such prices the
potential customers certainly seem
convinced by the farms pedigree horse
lovers like Charlie Watts from the
rolling stones along with American
millionaires and representatives from
the Arab Emirates on a shopping tour for
their rulers but could that now change
looks good continuity is very important
in breeding we're concerned that horses
will now be sold to make up the state
budget but if you sell too many good
horses too fast you ruin your breeding
marek trailer has received messages of
support from around the world but right
now he can do nothing it was especially
painful saying goodbye to the horses
they were all born during my tenure give
you up soon you are you would he go back
yeah I think I will have to go back to
clean up the mess he may well be right
two more horses have died under the new
director triggering a public
investigation the uproar over Poland
stud farms continues